مسرح الشارع رواجا واقبالا شرق السعوديه
حيث يمتاز بخروجه عن الطريقه المعتاده
للمسرح التقليدي هذا نوع مشاهدينا من الفن
بات يشكل اليوم انتشارا ملحوظا في
السعوديه بفضل قدرته على خلق مناخ تفاعلي
مع الجمهور وملامسه القضايا الاجتماعيه
المزيد مع الزميل علي
[موسيقى]
بعيدا عن خشبه المسرح التقليدي يحتل مسرح
الشارع حيزا من الاهتمام لدى عشاق العروض
المسرحيه لقربه من الجمهور خاصه وانه يؤدى
في الاماكن المفتوحه كاحد اساليب العرض
المسرحي الذي بات يشكل حضورا لافتا في
السعوديه طبعا المسرح المفتوح هو نوع من
انواع المسرح المعروف المقدمه عن عالميا
في عده دول متنوعه ولكن نحن حديثنا صرنا
نشوفه في المسرح السعودي حاضر طبعا عنده
خصوصيه للمسرح الشارع لانه متاح تقديمه في
اماكن مفتوحه
بثلاثه ما في ارتباط بمكان للعرض ولا
بتركيز على سينوقرافيا الاضاءه والصوت
لكن المعتمد تماما على اداء الممثلين على
فكره ونوعيه العرض ومكان العرض والتفاعل
المباشر مع الجمهور
بساطه مسرح الشارع وحواره المباشر مع
الجمهور استطاع خلق لغه من التقارب
والتفاعل ما بين الممثلين وردود فعل
الجمهور كما انه يستعرض قدره الممثلين على
الارتجال والبقاء وسط اجواء العرض دون
التاثر بالجمهور طبعا انا جربت كذا نوعين
المسرح اللي هو الشارع او خشبه المسرح
بالنسبه لي انا احب ان مسرح الشارع لايلي
ممتع جدا لاني اكون في وسط الناس وسط
الجمهور عاشر مشاعرهم اعرفها اتواصل معاهم
اكثر واكون بنفس المستوى معاهم فبالنسبه
لي انا مسرح الشارع حاجه جميله جدا المسرح
المفتوح يعطي
من يعني زوايا
كثيره بالنسبه للفنان والمشاهد يعني ويكون
قريب
الفنان من المشاهدين وكذلك المشاهد يكون
قريب يعني من
الجمهور من الممثل
اقترنا مسرحه الشارعي بالمناسبات الادبيه
ومحاكاته للحياه اليوميه ومناقشه القضايا
والموضوعات المجتمعيه معتمدا في ذلك على
فكره العرض واتاء الممثل في امكانيه ايصال
الفكره وتفعيل مشاركه الجمهور في مساحه
قريبه خارج الستاري الاحمر من المنطقه
الشرقيه عن اللغبي العربيه